سيدتي رئيسة مجلس النواب ، ألقى رئيس
الولايات المتحدة ، الرئيس ترامب ، خطابه عن
حالة الاتحاد قبل
انعقاد الكونجرس المنقسم بشكل مرير قبل ساعات فقط
من توقع أن يبرئه مجلس الشيوخ
في تلك الدقائق الـ 78 ، ليس مرة واحدة
ذكر فيها الرئيس عزله ولكن
حتى قبل أن يبدأ في التحدث  علامة
على التوتر بين ترامب ورئيسة مجلس
النواب نانسي بيلوسي ، رئيسة ترامب ، على
ما يبدو ، تجاهلت بيلوسي وهي
مددت يدها لتحييه قبل
أن تستدير وتهز كتفها أمام تجمعها.
الصداقة
لإنجاز المهمة للأشخاص ، سنعمل على إيجاد
أرضية مشتركة حيث يمكننا ولكننا
سنقف على أرض الواقع حيث لا يمكننا
فورًا بعد انتهاء الرئيس
من خطابه ، مزقت بيلوسي نسختها
من الخطاب على مرأى ومسمع من الكاميرات
الرئيس ترامب  استخدم العنوان
لإثبات قضية إعادة انتخابه مع
إبراز الاقتصاد والرش في اليد
من اللحظات المخصصة للتلفزيون ،
عاد زوجك من الانتشار ، إنه هنا معنا
الليلة ، ونحن
نشمل لم شمل عائلي عسكري ،
وسأطلب الآن من السيدة الأولى
للولايات المتحدة أن تقدم لك هذا
الشرف من فضلك حتى تكريم
المحافظ المثير للجدل  أعلن المذيع الإذاعي
راش ليمبو الحائز على الميدالية الرئاسية
للحرية ليمبو هذا الأسبوع
أنه يحارب سرطان الرئة المتقدم
حلفاء ترامب الجمهوريين أشادوا
بنقاط حديثه بينما جلس الديموقراطيون في الغالب في
صمت خلال المساء قدم
حاكمة ميتشيغان غريتشن ويتمر
رد الديمقراطيين
مستغلين الفرصة لتذكير الأمريكيين بأن
الرئيس  تم عزل ترامب ، الحقيقة
تهم الحقائق ولا ينبغي لأحد أن
يكون فوق القانون ،
فهذا ليس ما يقوله أعضاء مجلس الشيوخ
غدًا إنه يتعلق بما
يفعلونه ولكن في نهاية المطاف ، يحتل التنافس المرير
بين الرئيس وبيلوسي
مركز الصدارة في البيت الأبيض وترامب.
حلفاء الحزب الجمهوري ينتقدون المتحدثين في المنزل في
إشارة إلى أنه كان من العار  لقد كان أمرًا
مثيرًا للاشمئزاز أن تقوم بتمزيق الخطاب
ولكن لا يمكنك تمزيق
الإنجازات وهذا ما
سيحدثه هذا السباق في عام 2020 ،
يصر بعض الديمقراطيين على وجوب
توجيه الغضب إلى ترامب لاستخدامه
حالة الاتحاد كحملة.  رالي ، دعونا
نأمل ألا يصرف انتباهك عن قلة
الدقة الواقعية وسرعة
تقدم الجهاز على الشاطئ
والنداء الصارخ
لقاعدته والمشابه جدًا لخطبه في المسيرات ،
فقد كانت حالة من الاتحاد مصممة
لمناشدة  قاعدة عدم التقريب بين بلدنا